une neuvième édition qui s'achève sous
un timide rayon de soleil le temps
capricieux aura mis les hommes et les
machines à rude épreuve une compétition
pleine de suspense car dès le départ une
erreur de parcours réalisé par 11 des 19
candidats a chamboulé le classement
général malgré tout le champion du monde
alexandre barret s'impose à l'issue des
neuf manches
c'est surtout le physique après une très
bonne équipe moi j'ai une team energy
compétition qui est basée dans l'est de
la france qui est un très très gros
teams et savait que d'ailleurs qu'on a
tous remportés cette année donc
voilà un super type une bonne machine
des bons assistants sur place et puis
après mais après il faut un petit peu de
chance aussi mes romans tout va bien le
jeune guadeloupéen quant à meneaux a
surpris tout le monde
il arrive 3e en catégorie formule en a
18 ans et le premier ultra marins de la
course je pensais pas être à ce niveau
là actuellement et et on voit bien que
les emplois les entraînements ça paye il
me manque beaucoup d'heures
d'entraînement parce que cette année
j'ai eu un peu de mal
puis c'est le mental qui compte un mois
je fais du vélo donc j'ai un peu de
physique mais j'ai vraiment un mental
sérieux le premier martinique et ludovic
filippi réalise lui son objectif en se
hissant dans le top 10 pendant que le
champion christophe conte courrier à
suez des avaries mécaniques fatale lors
de cette compétition
je reprends une célèbre phrase du monde
une amie la course mécanique c'est
l'homme sa machine une grande part
d'inconnu l'inconnu l'inconnue pourquoi
il ya eu j'ai eu deux fois de suite j'ai
fait une manche à zéro
j'aurais pu être mieux classé que ça ma
batterie a éclaté pendant la course donc
remarqué 0 les dix-neuf concurrents ont
encore une fois assuré le spectacle
devant un public de tout âge
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour la
dixième édition où l'on annonce plein de
nouveautés